This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Mexico City in case you've never been, is full of distinctive sounds. There's the bell the garbage men ring letting you know when it's time to come down and throw out your trash. On some corners you can hear organ grinders cranking out tunes for tips. There are of course the roving mariachi bands. And there are the public markets where you can hear countless vendors hawking their products. But there's one specific sound that cuts through the den. A voice that, if you've never lavadoras, microondas, or something of fierrofias, what they sell.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。墨西哥城，如果你从未去过，那里充满了独特的声响。有垃圾收集工摇响的铃声，提醒你该下楼倒垃圾了。在一些街角，你可以听到手摇风琴师为了小费而演奏的曲调。当然，还有四处游走的墨西哥流浪乐队。还有公共市场，在那里你可以听到无数小贩在兜售他们的产品。但有一种特定的声音穿透了喧嚣。一个声音，如果你从未听过“洗衣机、微波炉，或者其他废旧金属”，也就是他们所卖的东西。
What you're hearing is a recording that trucks in Mexico City play on a relentless loop. Reporter Ted Seaford. The crews inside these trucks are looking to buy old household items and appliances. Basically, they're scrap metal haulers, and the recording is their pitch to perspective sellers. We buy mattresses, bed frames, refrigerators. The list of appliances continues with stoves, washing machines, and microwaves, and then crescendos gloriously with this line.
你现在听到的是墨西哥城的卡车上不断循环播放的录音。记者泰德·西福德。这些卡车里的工作人员正在寻找收购旧家电和旧物品。基本上，他们是废金属回收商，而这段录音就是他们对潜在卖家的推销词。我们收购床垫、床架、冰箱。家电清单还在继续，包括炉灶、洗衣机和微波炉，然后以这句台词华丽地推向高潮。
Which basically means, or any old metal thing you're selling. This last bit has become the recordings namesake, Fiero Viejo, the d'Orly Old Iron. The recording started popping up in neighborhoods surrounding the capital city in the early 2000s, but steadily the sound caught the attention of the internet and a growing number of amateur and not-so-amateur DJs and musicians. One of Mexico's major newspapers referred to Fiero Viejo as the most popular sound in all of Mexico. Its status as a national icon may have been cemented at the World Cup last year when a Mexican
这基本上意味着，或者任何你正在出售的旧金属制品。这最后一部分已经成为了这段录音的代名词，“Fierro Viejo”，即“旧铁”。这段录音在21世纪初开始出现在首都周边的社区，但随着时间的推移，这种声音引起了互联网以及越来越多的业余和非业余DJ和音乐人的注意。墨西哥的一家主要报纸将“Fierro Viejo”称为墨西哥最流行的声音。它作为国家标志的地位可能在去年的世界杯上得到了巩固，当时一位墨西哥
fan blasted it out of a massive speaker he had strapped to his back. So how and why did Fiero Viejo rise from the streets of Mexico City to become this huge sensation? The answer it turns out starts with a 9-year-old girl. A 9-year-old girl who helps solve a pressing challenge in a city that is busy, loud, and brimming with street vendors. Fiero Viejo is just one voice amid the cacophony of street selling in Mexico City. More than 50 percent, that's 5-0, of residents work in the informal economy. In a metro area of 22 million, that's a lot of vendors who go out every day, selling
球迷用他背在背上的巨大扬声器播放了这段录音。那么，“Fierro Viejo”是如何以及为什么从墨西哥城的街头崛起，成为这种巨大的轰动效应的呢？事实证明，答案始于一个9岁的小女孩。一个9岁的小女孩，她帮助解决了一个繁忙、嘈杂且挤满街头小贩的城市中一个紧迫的挑战。“Fierro Viejo”只是墨西哥城街头叫卖声喧嚣中的一个声音。超过50%，也就是5-0，的居民在非正规经济中工作。在一个拥有2200万人口的都市区，每天有大量的小贩走上街头，兜售
tamales, pressing fast juice, collecting all the appliances for scrap. The main driver of this massive part of the economy is necessity. There simply aren't enough jobs in Mexico's formal economy to go around. That makes streetbending both a crowded space and a competitive one. You can hear the intensity of that competition playing out at the public markets or Tiongis as the locals call them. There's a name for the calls vendors use to grab customers attention in the middle of all this commotion. They're called Pregones, and there's an art to them, one that's been refined over the centuries. This type of sound or this type of pregones that can be called names and have a story that's been reared in the past.
塔马利玉米粽，压制新鲜果汁，收集所有废旧家电。这个庞大经济部门的主要驱动力是需求。墨西哥的正规经济中根本没有足够的工作岗位。这使得街头兜售既是一个拥挤的空间，也是一个竞争激烈的空间。你可以在公共市场，或者当地人称之为“Tianguis”的地方，听到这种竞争的激烈程度。在所有这些骚动中，小贩用来吸引顾客注意力的叫卖声有一个专门的名称。它们被称为“Pregones”，而且它们是一门艺术，一种经过几个世纪提炼的艺术。这种声音或这种类型的“Pregones”可以被命名，并拥有一个在过去被培育出来的故事。
That's Liliana Hamika Silva. She's an anthropologist at the National School of Anthropology and History in Mexico City. She says the term Pregon has a long history in Mexico and can be traced back to the period of Spanish colonial rule. In those days, Pregonis referred to the Proclamation's a designated town cryer would make about new laws or notices of execution, that kind of thing. This purpose has, of course, fallen by the wayside, but the tradition of Pragonus has been carried on by street vendors who have long been important figures in Mexican culture. So we can already find in the movies, especially in the Mexican cinema, some of these like pregones, right? For example, there's a movie about...
那是莉莉安娜·哈米卡·席尔瓦。她是墨西哥城国立人类学与历史学院的人类学家。她说，“Pregon”一词在墨西哥有着悠久的历史，可以追溯到西班牙殖民统治时期。在那个时代，“Pregones”指的是指定的城镇传令官对新法律或处决通知等事项所做的公告。这种用途当然已经过时了，但“Pregones”的传统被街头小贩延续了下来，他们长期以来一直是墨西哥文化中的重要人物。所以我们已经在电影中，特别是在墨西哥电影中，可以找到一些这样的“Pregones”，对吧？例如，有一部关于……的电影。
Amica told me that street vendors and their Pregonists were often depicted during the Golden Age of Mexican cinema. In a 1951 film, you can hear the famed Mexican comic known as Teen Thanh, singing the praises of his freshly baked bread while riding his bike through the city. Panadero con el pan, tuntun el pan. Panadero con el pan.
哈米卡告诉我，街头小贩和他们的“Pregones”经常在墨西哥电影的黄金时代被描绘。在1951年的一部电影中，你可以听到著名的墨西哥喜剧演员，被称为“Tin Tan”，在骑自行车穿过城市时，歌颂他刚烤好的面包。面包师带着面包，咚咚，面包。面包师带着面包。
El panadero con el pan. El panadero con el pan. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada.
面包师带着面包。面包师带着面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。
Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada.
咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。
Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. Tundun, espada. breadsellers using that little horn which people associate with the bonadero. The street vendors you hear in Mexico City do not generally burst into song, but there remains an element of performance in their bregones. Vendors use distinctive intonations, cadences, and often clever turns of phrase to an effect to create their own sonic niches.
咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。咚咚，面包。面包师使用人们与面包师联系在一起的小喇叭。你在墨西哥城听到的街头小贩通常不会突然唱起歌来，但他们的“Pregones”中仍然保留着表演的成分。小贩们使用独特的语调、节奏，以及通常巧妙的措辞，来创造他们自己的声音利基。
This is especially important for itinerant vendors, the ones who sell their products and carts, trucks, or on foot. After all, they not only have to contend with the ambient noise of the city, but distracted customers who are busy doing other things. This recording is played by vendors who ride around selling tamales guajácños, tamales in the style of the wajáca region. Many mobile vendors, like the breadsellers, enhance their pagon with sounds like bells. And sometimes, the sound is so loud and so distinctive that no words are needed, like that
这对流动小贩尤其重要，也就是那些用手推车、卡车或步行兜售产品的人。毕竟，他们不仅要应对城市的背景噪音，还要应对忙于做其他事情而分心的顾客。这段录音是由兜售“瓦哈卡风味塔马利”的小贩播放的。许多流动小贩，像卖面包的一样，用铃铛等声音来增强他们的“Pregones”。有时，声音如此响亮且独特，以至于不需要任何言语，就像那个
of the sweet potato seller. The cart he pushes, by the way, is an ingenious contraption. A little wood fire steams the potatoes and powers that piercing whistle. Then there's the roving cooking gas seller, who opts for simplicity with his prugone. Before Fiero Viejo, the recording caught on, many scrap metal collectors shouted their pergones just like that gas cellar, and some, though not many, still do. And some, though not many, still do. And some, though not many, still do. Before it was the prisoner who was repeating it. Antes era el pregonero que lo iba repitiendo. Ahora ya es un caseto, es un disco, o sea, se han ido transformando
烤红薯小贩一样。顺便说一句，他推的那个车是一个巧妙的装置。一个小木火加热红薯，并驱动那个刺耳的哨子。还有那个四处游走的烹饪燃气小贩，他选择用简单的“Pregones”。在“Fierro Viejo”录音流行之前，许多废金属收集者就像那个燃气小贩一样大声喊叫他们的“Pregones”，有些人，虽然不多，现在仍然这样做。有些人，虽然不多，现在仍然这样做。有些人，虽然不多，现在仍然这样做。以前是传令官在重复它。以前是传令官在重复它。现在它是一个卡带，是一个唱片，也就是说，方式已经改变了，
las maneras, pero el significado y el uso, no? Amica explía que, while things like cassettes and CDs have changed the means by which vendors deliver their pergonis, their basic function has not changed. And Fiero Viejo may be the clearest and loudest expression of that trend. While the Fiero Viejo recording fits squarely into Mexico's rich tradition of pergones, it's also a stark departure from it, and that has everything to do with the voice that delivers it. and that has everything to do with the voice that delivers it. So high-pitched, it occupies its own sonic register. Each syllable delivered forcefully, it almost weirily.
但意义和用途没有变，对吧？哈米卡解释说，虽然像卡带和CD这样的东西改变了小贩传递“Pregones”的方式，但它们的基本功能并没有改变。而“Fierro Viejo”可能是这一趋势最清晰、最响亮的表达。虽然“Fierro Viejo”录音完全符合墨西哥丰富的“Pregones”传统，但它也与传统截然不同，这与传递它的声音有很大关系。这与传递它的声音有很大关系。音调如此之高，它占据了自己独特的声学音域。每个音节都强有力地传递出来，几乎令人毛骨悚然。
The incongruity of it is arresting. I don't know what causes the sound of the child, that all the dogs start to cry. For her part, Hamayke isn't sure what it is about the voice, but it does make all the dogs in her neighborhood howl. To get the story behind this iconic recording, I took a drive away from the swankier neighborhoods in Central Mexico City to a place called Icatipec, a sprawling dusty area of blocky buildings on the city's northern outskirts.
这种不协调感非常引人注目。我不知道是什么导致了孩子的声音，让所有的狗都开始叫。就她而言，哈米卡不确定这个声音到底有什么特别之处，但它确实让邻居所有的狗都嚎叫起来。为了了解这段标志性录音背后的故事，我开车离开了墨西哥城市中心那些更时髦的社区，前往一个叫“Ecatepec”的地方，这是一个位于城市北郊、建筑方方正正、尘土飞扬的广阔区域。
That's where I met Marco Antonio Tucho, in central Mexico City to a place called Icatibeck, a sprawling dusty area of blocky buildings on the city's northern outskirts. That's where I met Marco Antonio Taron and his family. Hey, can you tell me some words in English? Yes, I can. Marco's had many jobs in his nearly 60 years, cop, chef at a Japanese restaurant, bed frame seller, but the family business and his greatest love is entertainment.
就在那里，我遇到了马可·安东尼奥·图乔，在墨西哥城市中心，前往一个叫“Ecatepec”的地方，这是一个位于城市北郊、建筑方方正正、尘土飞扬的广阔区域。就在那里，我遇到了马可·安东尼奥·塔隆和他的家人。嘿，你能用英语告诉我一些词吗？是的，我可以。马可在近60年的时间里做过很多工作，警察、日本餐厅厨师、床架销售员，但家族生意和他最大的爱好是娱乐。
Hey, espaya, si, tajos, espaya, si to, y es chambonvita, y os e chambonvin. My daughter is a clown. But the family business and his greatest love is entertainment. My daughter is a clown. I'm a clown. Her stage name is Chimbon Vita. Mine is Chimbon V. However, making a living as a clown is not easy. Like everything, there's times when the clown business went down. The number of contracts went down. So talking with a cow's in a mind, he says, well, why don't you work with your brother who's already working in scrap metal? After a short time on his brother's scrap metal crew,
嘿，小丑，是的，小丑，是的，这是我的小丑生活。我女儿是个小丑。但家族生意和他最大的爱好是娱乐。我女儿是个小丑。我是个小丑。她的艺名是“Chimbon Vita”。我的是“Chimbon V”。然而，靠做小丑谋生并不容易。像所有事情一样，小丑生意也有低谷的时候。合同数量减少了。所以和一位小丑交谈时，他说，好吧，你为什么不和你已经在做废金属生意的兄弟一起工作呢？在兄弟的废金属团队工作了一段时间后，
Marco decided to venture out on his own. But he didn't have a truck, so he built a push car. And that's scrap metal crew, Marco decided to venture out on his own. But he didn't have a truck, so he built a push cart. And that's what he would use to load and move heavy appliances. He would push the cart under the hot sun, backening sellers by shouting through an improvised cardboard megaphone.
马可决定独自闯荡。但他没有卡车，所以他做了一个手推车。在那个废金属团队工作后，马可决定独自闯荡。但他没有卡车，所以他做了一个手推车。这就是他用来装载和搬运重型家电的东西。他会在烈日下推着车，通过一个简易的纸板扩音器大声呼唤卖家。
You can imagine that in a pie, you get wet. And you can imagine on foot your arrive exhausted. And after so much screaming my throat feels the same. With the sun, the heat, the dust, I had a sore throat, bad feet, super tired. I will take the boss to my house and there I will sit on the steps because my feet couldn't take it anymore. When they Marco had an idea, he would make a recording of his pitch, something other vendors sometimes did.
你可以想象，在路上，你会湿透。你可以想象步行到达时精疲力竭。在喊了那么多之后，我的喉咙感觉一样。伴随着太阳、热量、灰尘，我喉咙痛，脚疼，超级累。我会把老板带到我家，然后坐在台阶上，因为我的脚再也受不了了。当马可有一个想法时，他会把他的推销词录下来，这是其他小贩有时会做的事情。
That way he wouldn't have to strain his vocal cords all day. But Marco being Marco, he wanted to do the recording his own way. And since he felt his own voice was too low and gravely, he turned to his 9-year-old daughter for help. So I'm the original voice of the pregon. Se compran colchones, tambores, refrigeradores, estufas, lavagras, microondas, o algo de fija roviejo que venda. Meet Mary Mar, Taron Martinez, aka The Voice of Fear of YeHo. It wasn't exactly a stretch for Mary Mar, who is now 20 years old, to help out her father. She had already elbowed her way into his clown act.
这样他就不用整天拉伤声带了。但马可就是马可，他想用自己的方式录音。由于他觉得自己的声音太低沉沙哑，他向他9岁的女儿寻求帮助。所以我是“Pregones”的原始声音。“收购床垫、床架、冰箱、炉灶、洗衣机、微波炉，或者任何旧金属制品。”认识一下玛丽·玛尔·塔隆·马丁内斯，也就是“Fierro Viejo”之声。对于现在20岁的玛丽·玛尔来说，帮助她的父亲并不是什么难事。她已经挤进了他的小丑表演中。
Yo empecé a los 8 años. Yo le dije, ¿sabes qué papá? Yo quiero ser payacita y me siento panón, todavía no. I was say the other soul when I started. I say to him, you know what, Dad? I want to be a clown. And he was like, no, not yet. And I was like, yes, please, I want to be.
我从8岁开始。我对他说，你知道吗，爸爸？我想成为一名小丑，我感觉自己像个小丑，虽然还不是。我开始时是另一个灵魂。我对他说，你知道吗，爸爸？我想成为一名小丑。他就像，不，还不行。我就像，是的，拜托，我想成为。
And he will say, you're too small. And I was like, no, please, that until I convinced him. And he said, okay, fine. But now let me be. He said, well, no, it's okay, but it's okay. So it's okay. He's going with me. So the people are dying of laughter.
他会说，你太小了。我就像，不，拜托，直到我说服了他。他说，好吧，没问题。但现在让我来。他说，好吧，不，没关系，但没关系。所以没关系。他和我一起去。所以人们笑得要死。
Yeah, she will come with me and people die laughing. Because I fold down and she folds down. And we're dancing and my pants are falling off. And I'm trying to pick them down. And we're dancing and my pants are falling off. And I'm trying to pick them up. And we're still dancing. And I drop her and she falls on me. People thought it was hilarious. No, people attack this.
是的，她会和我一起去，人们笑得要死。因为我摔倒了，她也摔倒了。我们在跳舞，我的裤子掉了下来。我正试图把它们提起来。我们在跳舞，我的裤子掉了下来。我正试图把它们提起来。我们还在跳舞。我把她扔了，她摔在我身上。人们觉得这太搞笑了。不，人们攻击这个。
However, recording the pre-gone was no time for funny business. Marco is a bit of a perfectionist. Every word was rehearsed. And since she forget what she had to say, I will put drawings of a mattress on it, a drawing of a washing machine. So for her, it was easier to read. Marco and Marie-Mar did take after take after take after take, trying to get the sound
然而，录制“Pregones”可不是开玩笑的时候。马可有点完美主义。每一个字都经过排练。因为她会忘记她必须说什么，我会在上面画上床垫的图画，画上洗衣机的图画。所以对她来说，阅读更容易。马可和玛丽·玛尔录了一遍又一遍，一遍又一遍，试图让声音
right. They started recording at 12 o'clock at night and we finished at about 4 a.m. And that's because we wanted there to be no noise, but you know, there's always a dog that barked or some boyfriend who was looking for his girlfriend at 4 a.m. So suddenly, it was like, dog that bark or some boyfriend who was looking for his girlfriend at 4 a.m. So it took us several hours and I was very tired. And you could hear it.
正确。他们从晚上12点开始录音，大约凌晨4点结束。这是因为我们希望没有噪音，但你知道，总有一只狗在叫，或者某个男朋友在凌晨4点找他的女朋友。所以突然间，就像，狗在叫，或者某个男朋友在凌晨4点找他的女朋友。所以我们花了好几个小时，我非常累。你可以听出来。
All of the sudden I was like, say, come on, call John, and my dad will yell at me. Marimar, say come on, call John, he's done bodies. Or he was like, no, no, no colchones and my dad will yell at me. Marimar, say compran colchones, some bodies, and he was like, no, no, no, you're already falling asleep. And I was like, I'm tired.
突然间，我就像，说，收购床垫，我爸爸就会对我大喊。玛丽·玛尔，说收购床垫，床架。或者他就像，不，不，不，床垫，我爸爸就会对我大喊。玛丽·玛尔，说收购床垫，床架，他就像，不，不，不，你已经睡着了。我就像，我很累。
And he was like, I know, but let's try to make sure that the recording goes well. This may help explain these somewhat exasperated quality of the voice in Fiero Viejo. As much as Marie-Marre wants your old refrigerator, she also just wants to go to bed. Eventually, the cassette was finished and Marco began playing it on his rounds. Other scrap metal crews heard it and liked it. So Marco sold it to them for a pince, five paces,
他就像，我知道，但让我们试着确保录音效果好。这可能有助于解释“Fierro Viejo”中那种略带恼怒的声音特质。尽管玛丽·玛尔想要你那台旧冰箱，但她也只是想去睡觉。最终，卡带完成了，马可开始在巡回时播放它。其他废金属团队听到了，很喜欢。所以马可以五个比索的价格卖给他们，
the equivalent of about a quarter. La buena feza siempre tiene recompenses. Hay una cosa por tu compañero que es muy personal, ahí está, no más dá me lo descacé de cinco pesos. I believe that good faith always has rewards. You do one thing for your partner, like giving the cassette for five pesos, which is what it costs. But you take it, no problem. They are like crops you plant that will harvest later. And so steadily, the sound began to spread across the city,
相当于大约25美分。良好的信念总是有回报的。有一件事是为了你的同伴，这是非常私人的，就在那里，只要给我五个比索的卡带。我相信良好的信念总是有回报的。你为你的伙伴做一件事，比如以五比索的价格提供卡带，这就是它的成本。但你拿走它，没问题。它们就像你种下的庄稼，以后会收获。就这样，声音开始在城市中传播，
through the megaphone's and loudspeakers of a growing number of beat-up papers. And so, steadily, the sound began to spread across the city through the megaphone's and loudspeakers of a growing number of Mexico's massive informal economy. People have long carved out ways to make money whether or not the government approves of the activities. In fact, street fending is technically banned on the subway
通过越来越多的破旧卡车的扩音器和扬声器。就这样，声音开始通过越来越多的墨西哥庞大非正规经济的扩音器和扬声器在城市中传播。长期以来，人们一直在寻找赚钱的方法，无论政府是否批准这些活动。事实上，街头兜售在地铁上
and in parts of the historic center. Yet these settings are prime turf for vendors. So why do the authorities allow so many people to work on the streets? The short answer is they don't really have a choice. The state has no capacity to generate the conditions for there to be economic growth and employment. But it has the responsibility to attend to this people.
和历史中心的部分地区在技术上是被禁止的。然而，这些环境是小贩的主要地盘。那么，为什么当局允许这么多人上街工作呢？简短的回答是，他们真的别无选择。国家没有能力创造经济增长和就业的条件。但它有责任照顾这些人。
That's Carlos Alba Vega, a professor at the College of Mexico who has written books on the informal economy. Carlos says the Mexican state does not have the capacity to create the conditions for economic growth and jobs, but it does have the responsibility to serve those who work in the informal economy. The state says, among the companies, well, I don't have the possibility of helping you solve many problems. The state says in effect to street vendors,
那是卡洛斯·阿尔巴·维加，墨西哥学院的一位教授，他写过关于非正规经济的书。卡洛斯说，墨西哥国家没有能力创造经济增长和就业的条件，但它确实有责任服务那些在非正规经济中工作的人。国家说，在公司之间，好吧，我没有可能性帮助你解决许多问题。国家实际上对街头小贩说，
well, I can't help you solve many problems. You don't have social security. If you get sick, you're on your own. But what I can do is cover my eyes, so that you do what you need to do in itallery. So tolerance as a form of social redistribution. So tolerance as a form of social redistribution. Because there are laws in the books against many aspects
好吧，我不能帮你解决许多问题。你没有社会保障。如果你生病了，你只能靠自己。但我能做的是闭上眼睛，让你在里面做你需要做的事情。所以宽容作为一种社会再分配的形式。所以宽容作为一种社会再分配的形式。因为书面法律反对非正规商业的许多方面，
of informal commerce, enforcement often comes down to political expediency. This leaves a huge gray area, Because there are laws in the books against many aspects of informal commerce, enforcement often comes down to political expediency. This leaves a huge gray area governed by unspoken codes and occasional bribes. There is a regulation, but that regulation is not a formal regulation. It is an informal regulation. There are rules that are not written, that the people who live and work in these places existen reglas no escritas, que la gente que vive y trabaja en estos lugares conoce y respeta. Y si no lo respeta, le cuesta cargo, ¿no? can be severe consequences, including violence. As parts of Mexico City become more gentrified, there are signs that the tolerance alba refers
执法往往归结为政治权宜之计。这留下了一个巨大的灰色地带，由不成文的准则和偶尔的贿赂所支配。有规定，但该规定不是正式规定。它是一种非正式规定。有一些不成文的规则，生活和工作在这些地方的人知道并尊重。如果不尊重，代价是昂贵的，对吧？可能会有严重的后果，包括暴力。随着墨西哥城的部分地区变得更加绅士化，有迹象表明阿尔巴所指的宽容
to may be wearing thin. A recently enacted policy requires street food vendors in certain neighborhoods to display standardized signs with a city seal. This did away with a long, rich tradition of colorful, hand-painted stalls. The city also recently passed rules concerning noise pollution. While primarily aimed at construction sites and industrial businesses, it also applies to vehicles, and trucks blasting Furo Viejo would very likely exceed the 68 decibel limit. None of the scrap metal crews I spoke with said they had received any tickets or fines,
可能正在减弱。最近颁布的一项政策要求某些社区的街头食品小贩展示带有城市印章的标准化标志。这废除了长期以来丰富多彩、手绘摊位的传统。该市最近还通过了关于噪音污染的规定。虽然主要针对建筑工地和工业企业，但也适用于车辆，而播放“Fierro Viejo”的卡车很可能会超过68分贝的限制。我采访过的废金属团队中，没有一个人说他们收到过罚单或罚款，
but one guy did say that they were more likely to be hassled in certain areas. He said they sometimes have problems in wealthier neighborhoods, because people are bothered by the noise. And Fiero Viejo does have a way of injecting itself into one's daily life in Mexico City. This is something Mike Fortu was well aware of when he was studying music production about 10 years ago. He would often hear Fierro Viejo coming through the windows. It's so iconic, so loud. You can't even complain. I live here in an apartment, I hear it three times a day, and you can't be mad at it, you know, it's part of the city. One day, four two was struck by something in the recording, the rhythm. It has a lot of musical elements in it, and just the timber,
但有一个人确实说，他们在某些地区更容易受到骚扰。他说，他们在较富裕的社区有时会有问题，因为人们被噪音打扰了。而“Fierro Viejo”确实有一种方式可以注入墨西哥城的日常生活。这是迈克·福图在10年前学习音乐制作时非常清楚的事情。他经常听到“Fierro Viejo”穿过窗户传来。它太标志性了，太响了。你甚至不能抱怨。我住在这里的一间公寓里，我一天听到三次，你不能对它生气，你知道，它是城市的一部分。有一天，福图被录音中的某种东西打动了，节奏。它里面有很多音乐元素，还有这个小女孩的音色，
the timber of this little girl, I put this 128 BPM electronic music intro and stuff. And it absolutely matched like I didn't edit it much. And she just crashed the lines and lyrics. Soon, Fiero Viejo, the dance remix was born. For two, it may have been one of the first producers to sample Fiero Viejo, but he certainly was not the last. You can find tracks on Spotify and YouTube that riff on the Pregon in various ways. Probably the best produced song featuring Fiero Viejo dropped earlier this year. It's a collaboration between three producers and rappers who go by Oeix Coiotte, Fano
这个小女孩的音色，我放了这个128 BPM的电子音乐前奏之类的东西。它完全匹配，就像我没有做太多编辑一样。她只是冲破了台词和歌词。很快，“Fierro Viejo”舞蹈混音版诞生了。对于福图来说，他可能是第一批采样“Fierro Viejo”的制作人之一，但他肯定不是最后一个。你可以在Spotify和YouTube上找到以各种方式对“Pregones”进行即兴创作的曲目。今年早些时候发布的以“Fierro Viejo”为特色的制作最好的歌曲可能是这首。这是三位制作人和说唱歌手的合作，他们自称Oeix Coiotte、Fano
and Skiper. The video is excellent. The three rappers vamp it up like they're rolling in a tricked-out Lambo, but they're actually in an utterly ragged old pickup, piled high with old mattresses and junk. A way coyote told me it's sort of an homage. It's a celebration of doing what you have to do to make a living with a certain degree of style and ingenuity. In this sense, songs that sample fear of YeHo are about more than winking irony. They're about an identity. Here's Mike 4-2 again.
和Skiper。视频非常棒。这三位说唱歌手表现得好像他们开着一辆改装过的兰博基尼，但实际上他们是在一辆破旧不堪的皮卡车里，堆满了旧床垫和垃圾。A way coyote告诉我这是一种致敬。这是对以某种程度的风格和独创性做你必须做的事情来谋生的一种庆祝。从这个意义上说，采样“Fierro Viejo”的歌曲不仅仅是眨眼的讽刺。它们是关于一种身份。这是迈克·福图再次发言。
Yes, like if you play that, it's almost like an anthem, you know, you played it as you said in the World Cup and people are going to turn to find the wolf pack of the Mexicans, you know. We can be scattered around the world. And if you give us something to unite for and something to party, we're going to we're going to rug the night there. My interpreter, Jose Luis Viesca, a lifelong Mexico City resident artist and writer, had an interesting perspective on why fear of Viejo has resonated the way it has. It speaks, I think volumes, I think we're very proud of our creativity, how we always solve things like this, with three clips and one piece of
是的，就像如果你播放那个，它几乎就像一首国歌，你知道，你在世界杯上播放它，人们会转过身来寻找墨西哥人的狼群，你知道。我们可以分散在世界各地。如果你给我们一些团结起来的东西和一些庆祝的东西，我们就会在那里度过夜晚。我的翻译，何塞·路易斯·维斯卡，一位终身居住在墨西哥城的艺术家和作家，对为什么“Fierro Viejo”能产生这样的共鸣有一个有趣的视角。我认为它说明了很多问题，我认为我们为我们的创造力感到非常自豪，我们总是如何解决像这样的事情，用三个夹子和一块
tringo, but at the same time I think it's something to be expected from Mexicans. You will have somebody that takes a loud speaker on their back back in order to make noise, in order to attract attention, in order to precisely do something maybe surreal. Surreal might be a good way to describe how it felt for Marie-Mar when Fiero Viejo first started to spread across the city. She was self-conscious about her voice, and even she found it a bit intrusive. You're listening to a radio call, are you listening to the sound of the sound or are you
绳子，但同时我认为这是墨西哥人所期望的。你会有人背着扬声器，为了制造噪音，为了吸引注意力，为了精确地做一些也许超现实的事情。超现实可能是描述玛丽·玛尔在“Fierro Viejo”第一次开始在城市中传播时的感受的好方法。她对自己的声音感到不自在，甚至她觉得它有点侵入性。你在听广播，你在听声音的声音，还是你在
listening to a romantic moment with the sound of the sound of the sound? You're taking a shower, you're in a meeting, you're talking on the phone, you're arguing with your husband or you're having a romantic moment with your husband and the recording place. So you hear the recording a lot all day long, a hell of a lot. Despite her initial misgivings, Marie-Mar has embraced the fame that comes with Fiero Viejo's popularity. She's performed Fiero Viejo live and she's set for interviews with prominent TV journalists. She's even active on social media, under the names Lavos Del Fiero Viejo and Niña Del
听着浪漫的时刻，伴随着声音的声音？你在洗澡，你在开会，你在打电话，你在和丈夫争吵，或者你正在和丈夫享受浪漫时刻，录音就开始播放了。所以你整天听到很多录音，非常多。尽管最初有疑虑，玛丽·玛尔还是接受了“Fierro Viejo”流行带来的名声。她现场表演过“Fierro Viejo”，并准备接受著名电视记者的采访。她甚至在社交媒体上很活跃，名字是“Lavos Del Fiero Viejo”和“Niña Del
Viejo. Literally, girl of iron. And social media has helped Marie-Mar and Fiero Viejo gain an international fanbase. Versions of the Pregon have been posted in other languages on TikTok and Instagram, like this one in French. De tom buch, de frigo, de gazinier, de machinaleve, de micrôles. Mary Mar has also used her fame to call attention to more serious matters, like Mexico's high rates of violence against women and femicide.
Viejo”。字面意思是，铁女孩。社交媒体帮助玛丽·玛尔和“Fierro Viejo”获得了国际粉丝群。在TikTok和Instagram上，人们用其他语言发布了“Pregones”的版本，比如这个法语版本。床垫，冰箱，燃气灶，洗衣机，微波炉。玛丽·玛尔也利用她的名声来呼吁人们关注更严重的问题，比如墨西哥针对女性的高暴力率和杀害女性事件。
Last year for International Women's Day, trucks rode through the streets of Mexico City, blaring what sounded like fear of Yeo, but with a very different set of messages. International Women's Day was one of the few times Mary Mar agreed to lend the tune and her magnificent pipes to alternate versions of Fierro Viejo. In this clip, the Pregonis played from speakers in the Zocalo, the massive historic plaza in the heart of Mexico City, the word say in part. We invite you to the struggle that demands respect, equality and justice for us and the new generations. Marco and Mary-Mar hosted me earlier this year in the front yard of their home,
去年国际妇女节，卡车穿过墨西哥城的街道，播放着听起来像“Fierro Viejo”的声音，但带有非常不同的信息。国际妇女节是玛丽·玛尔同意将曲调和她宏伟的嗓音借给“Fierro Viejo”替代版本的少数几次之一。在这个片段中，“Pregones”是从墨西哥城市中心巨大的历史广场Zocalo的扬声器中播放出来的，部分词句是。我们邀请你们参加要求尊重、平等和正义的斗争，为了我们和新一代。马可和玛丽·玛尔今年早些时候在他们家的前院接待了我，
a small house with a cement floor that they share with Mary-Mar's three kids Despite the famed fiaro viejo is brought them the family still hustles to make ends meet Marco for his part believes they haven't always gotten there do He considers fiaro viejo an artistic creation and he says he's registered it and retained a lawyer And the idea is well those who can pay if registered and retained a lawyer. The idea is that those who can pay should pay. Songs, comedies, movies, short films. If they want to use it, they should pay because they can afford it. But for the carreteros, the people who buy scrap metal,
一个有着水泥地面的小房子，他们和玛丽·玛尔的三个孩子住在一起。尽管“Fierro Viejo”给他们带来了名声，但这个家庭仍然在努力维持生计。马可认为他们并没有总是得到应有的回报。他认为“Fierro Viejo”是一种艺术创作，他说他已经注册并聘请了一名律师。这个想法是，那些能付钱的人如果注册并聘请了律师，就应该付钱。歌曲、喜剧、电影、短片。如果他们想使用它，他们应该付钱，因为他们负担得起。但对于“Carreteros”，那些收购废金属的人，
it's very difficult, very difficult. Marco doesn't collect scrap metal as much as he used to, but he's still very much involved in the industry. Knowing how challenging the work can be, he started a union for collectors. Members get help repairing their trucks dealing with the authorities and unlimited access to the recording of Fiero Viejo. There is at least one constant in the lives of Marco and Mary-Mar since the days he was pushing a
这非常困难，非常困难。马可不像以前那样收集废金属了，但他仍然非常参与这个行业。知道这项工作有多么具有挑战性，他为收集者成立了一个工会。成员们可以获得修理卡车、处理当局事务的帮助，并可以无限次使用“Fierro Viejo”的录音。自从他推着
cart and hollering out of a cardboard tube. They still perform as clowns. Only now, Fiero Viejo has become central to their act. To true this, it surprises me when we go to events and do that number. You have to tell me a sound from Mexico City. And the children start the one with the water, the one with the gas, the fiero viejo. And then they start, se compran colchones. And it's something really cool. It's something that I love to do.
手推车并从纸板管中大声呼喊的日子以来，马可和玛丽·玛尔的生活中至少有一个常数。他们仍然以小丑的身份表演。只是现在，“Fierro Viejo”已经成为他们表演的核心。真的，当我们去参加活动并做那个节目时，这让我感到惊讶。你必须告诉我一个来自墨西哥城的声音。孩子们开始玩水，玩燃气，玩“Fierro Viejo”。然后他们开始，收购床垫。这真的很酷。这是我喜欢做的事情。
Y es algo padrísimo, es algo que me encanta hacer. It's something that I love to do. And it's something that I love to do. Making a living collecting household castoffs for scrap isn't easy. By crafting what is basically an extremely effective advertisement, the Torontoes ease the toil not only for themselves, but for legions of collectors in Mexico. But it wasn't just what those scrap metal trucks were collecting. It's what they ended up offering, the unbridled, unbouded shout of a nine-year-old girl, that for some reason echoed across Mexico and then the world.
这太棒了，这是我喜欢做的事情。这是我喜欢做的事情。这是我喜欢做的事情。靠收集家庭废弃物为生并不容易。通过制作一种基本上极其有效的广告，塔隆一家不仅减轻了他们自己的辛劳，也减轻了墨西哥无数收集者的辛劳。但那些废金属卡车收集的不仅仅是这些。他们最终提供的是一个9岁女孩肆无忌惮、无拘无束的呐喊，出于某种原因，它在墨西哥乃至全世界回荡。
More on the sounds of Mexico City, after the break. So we are back with Ted Seifer, who has more to tell us about some of the street-winning calls you heard earlier. Hey, Ted, hey, so you may have noticed the recordings of some of those calls, specifically those in the public markets were really well done. I did notice that. I mean, many of them were just really clean and crisp. chico pesos. Like that one, you can even hear his intake of breath. It's that clean. I know.
休息后，更多关于墨西哥城的声音。我们回来了，和泰德·西福德在一起，他有更多关于你之前听到的一些街头叫卖声的信息。嘿，泰德，嘿，所以你可能注意到了那些叫卖声的录音，特别是公共市场里的那些，做得非常好。我确实注意到了。我的意思是，其中许多非常干净清晰。五个比索。就像那个，你甚至可以听到他吸气的声音。它就是那么干净。我知道。
So I can't take credit for that recording. More for some of the other ones that we heard of the market vendors. They were made by a French sound engineer and sound artist named Felix Bloom. He first came to Mexico City in 2009, and he was staying in the historic center of the city. So it's super quiet during the night.
所以我不能把功劳归于那个录音。更多的是我们听到的其他市场小贩的录音。它们是由一位名叫菲利克斯·布鲁姆的法国录音工程师和声音艺术家制作的。他于2009年首次来到墨西哥城，当时他住在城市的历史中心。所以晚上非常安静。
It's really silent, probably one of the most historic center of the city. So it's super quiet during the night, it's really silent, probably one of the most silent places of the city. But during the day, you have hundreds and hundreds of people, street sellers screaming and announcing what they are selling and people going through. And it was amazing for me to be there and to listen to all those sounds. So Felix, sound artist that he is, wanted to record the vendors. So he got to know some of them and started recording their pergones one-on-one,
它真的很安静，可能是城市中最安静的地方之一。但在白天，你有成百上千的人，街头小贩在大声叫卖他们卖的东西，人们穿行其中。对我来说，在那里聆听所有这些声音真是太棒了。所以菲利克斯，作为一名声音艺术家，想要录制小贩的声音。所以他结识了他们中的一些人，并开始一对一地录制他们的“Pregones”，
away from the noise of the public markets. And these recordings would become the basis for an exhibition that ran a few years ago called Coro Informal, which means informal chorus. It was held at a place called the Phonoteca, a sound library and cultural center in Mexico City. Basically, when visitors walked in, they'd see all these little wooden boxes and when people opened them, out came a pergone.
远离公共市场的噪音。这些录音将成为几年前举办的一个名为“Coro Informal”（意为“非正式合唱团”）展览的基础。它在墨西哥城的Phonoteca举行，这是一个声音图书馆和文化中心。基本上，当参观者走进去时，他们会看到所有这些小木盒，当人们打开它们时，就会传出“Pregones”。
And then they could also see its musical score along with an illustration of the bender. I wanted to be beautiful in life. I wanted to be beautiful in life. I wanted to be beautiful in life. I wanted to be beautiful in life. I wanted to be beautiful in life. I wanted to be beautiful in life. I wanted to be a little girl, but I wanted to be a little girl, I wanted to be a little girl, I wanted to be a little girl, I wanted to be a little girl, I wanted to be a little girl, Wow, that is so amazing. What a great exhibit.
然后他们还可以看到它的乐谱以及小贩的插图。我想在生活中变得美丽。我想在生活中变得美丽。我想在生活中变得美丽。我想在生活中变得美丽。我想在生活中变得美丽。我想在生活中变得美丽。我想成为一个小女孩，但我想要一个小女孩，我想要一个小女孩，我想要一个小女孩，我想要一个小女孩，我想要一个小女孩，哇，那太棒了。多么棒的展览。
And also just like, so fiercely, it was so useful for our story to have all these clean, beautiful recordings that he made. Totally. But Felix was not content just to be a documentarian. He decided that he would try his hand at street bending as well. So he makes a CD called disco pirata, which means pirate CD.
而且，他制作的所有这些干净、美丽的录音对我们的故事也非常有用。完全正确。但菲利克斯并不满足于仅仅做一个记录者。他决定也尝试一下街头兜售。所以他制作了一张名为“Disco Pirata”的CD，意思是“盗版CD”。
Viva Mexico! Cielo son ellos. Viva, te quedo por reje! Más de tres horas de duración. That's Felix in the intro to the CD, saying it's three hours long with over 100 sounds of the city. Whoa, okay. It's pretty ambitious.
墨西哥万岁！天空是他们的。万岁，我为你留下了！超过三个小时的长度。那是菲利克斯在CD前言中说的，说它有三个小时长，有超过100种城市的声音。哇，好吧。这很有野心。
Basically, Felix styled the disc after the Pirate CDs that you can find being hocked in public markets and subway cars. They made offer, say, the top 100 Cumbia or regatone hits of the current day. As you can imagine, Felix's desk did not just feature jams like Furo Viejo, but deep cuts like the balloon vendor. And the knife sharpener. Felix then boarded subway cars and tried to sell the CD in the committed to the bit. I mean, it's pretty gutsy to, you know, sell your Pregonis CD with a French accent, you
基本上，菲利克斯模仿了你在公共市场和地铁车厢里兜售的盗版CD的风格。他们可能会提供，比如说，当今排名前100的Cumbia或Reggaeton热门歌曲。你可以想象，菲利克斯的唱片不仅有像“Fierro Viejo”这样的热门歌曲，还有像卖气球的这样的小众曲目。还有磨刀匠。菲利克斯随后登上了地铁车厢，并试图兜售这张CD，致力于这个角色。我的意思是，用法国口音兜售你的“Pregones”CD，你知道，在拥挤的地铁车厢里，像，他最终卖出了很多吗？好吧，从商业角度来看，它并不那么成功。他说他只卖了几张唱片。所以大声喊叫并不容易。然后我遇到了当时卖唱片的人，他们说，好吧，你应该这样做，你应该走这条线，绿线，绿线对你更好，因为它像大学，他们会喜欢这种东西。他们甚至试图为我卖掉它。
know, like on a crowd in some way, Kar like, did he end up selling a bunch of these? Well, from a commercial perspective, it wasn't so successful. He said he only sold a few desks. So it wasn't so easy to scream. And then I met some people selling disk at this time and they said, well, you should do it like this, you should go on this line, the green line, the green line is better for you because it's like university and they would like this kind of stuff. And they even tried to sell it for me.
我给了，好吧，我可以给你几份，试着卖掉它。所以其他小贩给了他关于如何同时大声喊叫和卖东西的建议。这真的很棒。听起来菲利克斯真的被墨西哥城的声音所启发。我的意思是，你从他那里感觉到他在存档和展示这些声音时，他的艺术追求到底是什么吗？
I gave, well, I can give you a few copies and try to sell it. So the other vendors were giving them pointers for how to shout and sell some things at the same time. That's really amazing. It sounds like Felix was really inspired by the sounds of Mexico City. I mean, did you get a sense from him like what he was really going for in his art when he was archiving these and presenting them?
是的，我们聊过这个。他的目标之一绝对是纪录片，对吧？他想录制小贩的叫卖声，因为它们是城市身份中如此容易被忽视和短暂的一部分。我认为录音的行为通常就像建立一个地方的记忆，它是从一个时刻或从生活在这些领土上的人们那里建立记忆，或者可能那些声音会消失，在某些时候我会改变，至少。所以我个人经历了菲利克斯在这里谈论的事情，
Yeah, we chatted about that. One of his goals was definitely documentary, right? He wanted to record the vendor calls because they are such an easily overlooked and a femoral part of the city's identity. I think the act of recording in general, it's like building a memory of a place, it's building a memory from a moment or from people living these territories, or probably those sound will disappear, at some some points I will change, at least. So I personally experienced what Felix is talking about here,
城市的声音是如何随着时间的推移而变化和演变的。例如，这是菲利克斯录制的塔马利小贩的声音。塔马利，瓦哈卡风味，热腾腾的塔马利。这是同一个人录制的“Pregones”，请注意，我在城里时听到的。我的意思是，我个人喜欢现在的这个。歌词，可以说，更复杂。它有一个很好的流动性。当你花很多时间，也许太多时间听“Pregones”时，这些就是你开始注意到的事情。
how the sounds of the city change and evolve over time. For example, this is Felix's recording of a tamale vendor. Ita males, guajacuños, tamales, calientitos. And here's the progón by the same guy mind mind you that I heard when I was in the city. I mean, I personally like the current one. The lyrics, so to speak, are more complex. It's got a nice flow. These are the kind of things that you start to notice when you spend a lot of time, maybe too much time listening to Pragonus.
无论如何，菲利克斯尝试捕捉和保存这些声音很重要，但他对他的声音项目还有另一个目标。这与公共空间的概念有关。公共空间是一个让所有人都能被听到的空间。这一切都发生在公共空间。我认为这就是聆听这个公共空间的重要之处，去听人们想说什么，去听人们在说什么，也许没有足够多的人在听他们。这太真实了，我很高兴有更多的人在听。
Anyway, it was important for Felix to try and capture and preserve these sounds, but he had another goal with his sound projects. And that has to do with the notion of public space. The public space is a space for all in the place to be able to be listened. And this all happens is a public space. And I think that's the important things of listening to this public space, to listen to what people want to say, to what people are saying, and maybe not enough people are listening to them. That's so true, and I'm so glad that more people are listening.
我很高兴这个故事，我能亲自听到这些“Pregones”。所以我真的很感激，泰德。谢谢。绝对的。这是我的荣幸，罗曼。这是一个非常有趣的故事。本周的《99%隐形》由泰德·西福德制作，杰森·德·莱昂编辑，事实核查由索娜·阿瓦金完成，配音由约翰·拉切·维加和劳拉·奥巴特完成，本周由泰德·西福德制作，杰森·德·莱昂编辑，事实核查由索娜·阿瓦金完成，配音由约翰·拉切·维加和劳拉·奥巴特完成，原创音乐由斯旺·里豪创作，声音混音由
And I'm so happy with the story, and I get to hear these progones for myself. So I really appreciate it Ted. Thank you. Absolutely. It was my pleasure, Roman. It was a really fun story to work on. 99% of Lisbon was produced this week by Ted Sefer and edited by Jason De Leon, fact-checking by Sona Avakin, boys overworked by Johann Rache Vega and Laura Obate, This week by Ted Sefer and edited by Jason De Leon, fact checking by Sona Avakin, boys overworked by Johann Rache Vega and Laura Obate, original music by Swan Rihau, sound mix by
我非常喜欢这个故事，我也能亲自听到这些进展。所以我真的很感激，泰德。谢谢你。当然。这是我的荣幸，罗曼。这是一个非常有趣的故事。本周的《99%无形》由泰德·塞弗制作，杰森·德·莱昂编辑，索娜·阿瓦金负责事实核查，约翰·拉切·维加和劳拉·奥巴特负责配音，本周由泰德·塞弗制作，杰森·德·莱昂编辑，索娜·阿瓦金负责事实核查，约翰·拉切·维加和劳拉·奥巴特负责配音，原创音乐由斯旺·里豪创作，声音混音由
Martin Gonzalez. Delaney Hall was our senior editor, Kurt Colstead is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Lang, Chris Baroube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Kelly Prime, Lashmadan, Jacob Moltenonna Medina, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Jose Luis Vieska, Aaron Reese, Jorge Mendoza, Eric Cernaluna, Felix Bloom, and to Marco and Mary Mar, to Rome. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family,
Martin Gonzalez。Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑，Kurt Colstead是我们的数字总监。团队其他成员包括Vivian Lang、Chris Baroube、Emmett Fitzgerald、Christopher Johnson、Kelly Prime、Lashmadan、Jacob Moltenonna Medina、Joe Rosenberg，以及我Roman Mars。99% Invisible的标志由Stefan Lawrence创作。本周特别感谢Jose Luis Vieska、Aaron Reese、Jorge Mendoza、Eric Cernaluna、Felix Bloom，以及Marco和Mary Mar，还有Rome。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一员，
now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to others' Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99
现在总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼。就在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99% Invisible的每一期往期节目，
PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是99PI.org。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。